[Music]
new to the job and new to this world
stage the Prime Minister meeting
friendly leaders at the opening of the
G20 Summit in Indonesia
but for all the brief moments of levity
heavy issues around this table Russia's
continued war in Ukraine weigh in on the
world
Rishi soon at glaring at Russia's
foreign minister from across the room
moscow's war with Ukraine heart in the
global economy making his job harder but
so did his predecessor Liz Tross blew an
enormous 30 billion pound black hole in
the public finances this is I think like
the modern Tory party's black Wednesday
if you want to move on for this don't
you need to start by saying sorry to the
British people about what's just passed
on the steps of Downing Street when I
first
prime minister was to fix them no one's
apologized the Prime Minister refusing
six times to say sorry for the economic
turmoil caused by the party he leads no
one apologized people can't pay their
mortgages potentially people are
struggling with food bills no one has
taken responsibility were you now say to
the British people let them say I'm
sorry they messed up I'm going to try
and fix it we've actually seen all those
UK specific factors in terms of how much
we borrow what's happened to the pound
those those have all considerably
improved and what we're now facing are
the same challenges that many of the
countries here are facing as well Russia
won Challenge and the PM seeking out
countries that don't see eye to eye
such as Saudi Arabia and China a big
Focus too this a PM who has taught tough
but now wants to engage do you think you
can have have a collaborative
relationship with President XI I think
it's an indisputable fact of the global
economy that China is a big part of it
and if we want to solve big Global
challenges like public health like
Russia and Ukraine fixing the global
economy or indeed climate change it's
important to have a dialogue and to
engage with China as part of solving
those challenges you said to me last
night you were hopeful you'd be the
first prime minister to meet president
XI for a few years for any British prime
minister are you going to meet him I'm
hopeful that I can I mean this as I said
I think it's important that we engage
with people to try and tackle some of
these shared challenges and I'm here to
talk to people and that's what I hope is
possible tonight a relaxed Rishi sunak
making it all look possible at a G20
welcome dinner but for all these leaders
meeting in the shadow of War these are
challenging times especially for an
unproven prime minister about to deliver
us all bad news Beth Rigby Sky News
barley in Indonesia